this is home spa bomber you can see over
there another rocket landed one of the
civilians houses this has been going on
all all day long from 5am it's about 8am
right now it is going to keep going on
in 3-7 p.m. this is alive who's got used
to rockets but it's getting children
denim Street body parts wise in your own
helping us where's the humanity in the
world where's in un why did I won't do
it and think about this these animals
only civilian houses over there are
these human beings different now that
was another rocket landed over there so
this is this is happening every day this
is hamid reza un where's his humanity
where's America where's America is an
American soldiers defending humanity is
the new encerrado defending humanity are
we animals dying here are we supposed to
live like this our home ice
Syria hopes this is Bob armor this is
one neighborhood bahama imagine what's
going on all over Syria then this is one
neighborhood in homs is one of the
nurseries and baba Baba just hit us with
mortar bombs and tank shells and rockets
you can see they've done it up then and
there in the buildings it's it also
brilliant houses you can see it all the
grounds you can see how the Rockets have
landed here there's one of seven people
dead just in this street women children
men you can see the whole street the
bodies on there there's bodies in that
house pieces of bodies in that house
this is a civilian house this is where
civilians it burns when Jesus the pieces
of what is are still in here
but that's all these are bodies these
are civilian bodies these are civilian
bodies this is in the army there's a
children men women being killed whether
you end we don't want monitors again we
want the UN to interfere with the army
this is one of the houses of Babylon oh
look at these children this how the
Assad regime is supposed to treat our
children now see what Assad regime that
is killing children was that you ain't
going to do about this what is that you
ain't going to do about this nothing
they're going to sit and discuss and see
what they want to do this peacefully
they were solid peacefully with this
matter of the way to these children
they've been hearing us from 6am until
it's 2pm now we have over a hundred
bodies over 200 underneath the
destructions we don't even know who they
are and this is only in one area and
homes look at the children how can you
stand and watch these children be like
this I like a lady
you